The joe rogan experience.
You know what,
man?
I think there's a problem with commentary with sports that leaks into MMA and I
don't think it belongs there.
And I've fought against it from the beginning and that's the,
the insult commentary.
There's a kind of like calling people bombs and calling people losers and you
know,
get out of the game.
Snoop Dogg that piece of shit.
Do you know how to call them out?
What?
What's what?
Daniela,
please do call a quarter.
Oh,
Mary called him a bitch.
That was a mess.
That's not cool either.
Fight.
That was a mess.
I think he was fucked up.
I don't care.
Yeah.
You know,
you put it on public,
he could,
you know,
apologize,
delete it,
whatever,
you know?
Yeah.
If I go to the UFC,
Pii am I just punch him.
If I see a man,
I'm cool with that.
What else do you don't want?
None of that snoop.
I'm just saying,
I really offends me man,
because you know what man?
Conor,
you know people all have their opinions about them.
I respect the shit out of that guy.
I love what he's done.
I love,
I love his shtick.
Um,
I think he's a,
he's a true,
uh,
sportsman.
I mean,
I like him.
He comes into the limelight for a little while and then he goes back and I think
he goes back and he works his ass off.
I really think he does.
Definitely does.
I mean,
he wouldn't be where he's at if he didn't write,
you know,
but everybody judges him by,
what he,
he does out here.
Well,
listen,
what he did was make $100 million fighting against the greatest boxer of all
time for professional boxing.
Match ended well and won a couple of rounds,
which is fucking crazy.
Yeah.
That's fucking crazy.
I mean,
I think Floyd,
I think,
I think the vast majority of people could,
uh,
of good fighters could win around,
so against Floyd,
because Floyd,
I don't know if I say gives them away,
but you know,
he's going to feel you.
He,
you know what I mean?
He's,
that's the way he fights.
he thought everybody like that and he rarely wins the first few rounds.
Agreed.
Yeah.
But that's not taken away.
Nothing from Connor though.
He didn't want to get clipped by that.
Left or cut.
Did Not.
It wasn't on plans.
You're right.
Yeah.
I just think that what I'm talking about,
it's like the commentators and a lot of the journalists and you see less of it
today because I stayed even a Smith.
Yeah.
That kind of style.
There's a style and this is their stick.
Their stick is mocking people and creating controversy and I,
that's why I say I don't think MMA is a sport.
I think it's more intense.
It's you're empty and out there,
you know when you see a fight,
you know,
and it's a crazy ass war,
like Robbie Lawler Hofeld Los Angeles,
where it's just five rounds of chaos to diminish either one of these guys as a
man,
as a human being based on their performance to mock them or belittle them.
I just don't think it has any place in that.
I think it's a way more intense and way more personal experience for those guys.
It's not,
it's not playing baseball.
it's not fucking bill Buckner dropping a ball.
It's not,
that's not what it is,
man.
It's way more intense.
If you got a guy who,
a lazy football player,
it doesn't run fast enough.
You want to mock them tasks,
whatever,
you go ahead and do that.
I don't care.
It doesn't bother me.
But you want to make fun of a guy who was literally putting his health on the
line in a,
in an occupation where you're competing against a motherfucking trained killer
and you guys are gonna throw bones at each other for five minute rounds.
You got to have some respect.
You have to have respect or you shouldn't be talking about it.
You should have some understanding of it.
You should know what the fuck you're watching and you should have some respect.
And if you want to say that a guy should retire the,
if you want to say that a guy is probably seen as better days,
that's fine,
but have some respect.
This is a different thing,
man.
It is not a regular sport.
I agree.
And not that I would say also the,
uh,
they have no right to be saying things that they've never done right.
Yeah,
I mean,
you,
you just can't,
you don't have to compete,
right?
Like you do Jujitsu and more time shit,
and you get such a more in depth knowledge about what they're truly going
through.
Right.
And what's happening by just experiencing it a little bit.
There's that,
and there's also,
I think if you've never really been punched in the face and you're,
you're talking about guys getting punched in the face,
like you really don't even understand the experience.
Okay.